bene tutti ragazzi e femmine debito
video sono parigi oggi siamo su file
nights freddy's in guardia perché non è
il fatto che cerca me sono io che cerco
l'infarto che bello dove leonora che
uscisse file del freddo in più ai
ragazzi il dottore mi ha detto che se
voglio vivere fino a 30 anni devo
smetterla però ormai finiamo lì come si
devono sì trent'anni a questo si che una
non è vero spedì seguono un mio dio
ora vado a fare il fruttivendolo ciao
ragazzi come fu cosa devo fare qua c'è
una scienza ai una cosa in mano che è
più brutali de e fidati che ce ne vuole
allora io non potevo fare video come
mette deezer non ci permettere mike hall
meeting che significa ho bisogno di
aiuto di ora in un sacco bisogno di
aiuto dopo questo video prova niente
continui anche se non ho mai giocato
continua va bene come sono protetto di
finire la mia vita oggi allora è mai
tonight 2 posso cliccare su night uno
tanto si genera una pizza quando io
piccole cose che figata il gioco del
secolo è un lounge bar
pronto allora non ti voglio sentire
basta ma com'è possibile
stai zitto stai zitta mi scusi mi scusi
quanta chiare che mi dà fastidio
ecco come funziona stai zitto e non
fuoco
ecco ti do fuoco aspetta do do fuoco al
telefono stai zitto stai zipper cortesia
la smettiamo mamma mia che fastidio non
c'è modo per spegnere sta roba
ok aspetto vetro dell'atmosfera e della
allegra e di questo sono incredibilmente
contento come devo morire in questo
gioco a lei lo schiaccia cambiare nuova
aveva più figata lo schiaccio e cambia
le camere ragazzi li vedo tutti bene
allora quelli che stanno tutti in fondo
fantastico qua ce n'è stato uno che si
sta avvicinando bene così io so io sono
qua quindi devo stare attento alle porte
vicine quindi questa qua è questa qua
giusto devo anche è successo oggi devo
anche spegnere l'interruttore della luce
perché sono la corrente da al cento per
cento continua scelta quindi dello
spegnere le cose se va bene deve
resistere fino alle 6 del mattino sennò
muoio questa cosa purtroppo è sempre
così preferirei morire adesso almeno
nove ragazzi veramente troppo immersivo
cioè io sempre hanno di fatto convoglio
sul serio ma scusami mi dice che va a
sinistra
ah no c'è questa io io vedo solo questo
pezzettino piccolo può trovare che sta
arrivando è successo questo ruolo
raga è potrebbero
giulia volta facciamo cacciare ciò che
posso per mario no ragazzi ma veramente
no ma io non ci posso fare mai un gesto
modello
ma se n'è andato il tizio che non ho
capito se n'è andato posso aprire
perfetto a posto tutto di tutto ok tutto
sotto processo bordello se guardi non
vogliamo i testimoni di geova non so se
era un festino
sto scherzando era ironica abbattuta
guardi mi sa che hai sbagliato persona
non so io sono solo uno youtuber ecco è
visto che l'ho convinta possiamo mettere
tom e jerry sulla tv questa roba da
spegnere
no ragazzi si sta scaricando la corrente
ragazzi si sta scaricando la corrente
sono riciclati non manca un ora mancava
ancora vi prego non è abbassata la tua
famiglia
non è vero o no no per favore non
annuncia posso fare io con una digiuno
segreto di fatto come ammazzo sono fatte
credibile che c'è
grazie gesù ero morto ero morto se sta
roba qua ma che restano da qui no no no
no tua sorella presero ma qua non ho
cambiato per cortesia progetto schifo ma
non posso marius thorp semi spunto via
io vi ammazzo ve lo giuro
[Musica]
a posto sono patatine disappointment ma
va bene sono patatine possono andare
sapevano un po di piedi però ho ragazzi
primo tentativo ce l'ho fatta non è da
me che strano va bene ragazzi questa è
la prima notte ma voglio sapere come
sono le altre guarda
basta questo telefono avere rotto e
valle si può spegnere beh allora abbiamo
scherzato
ora facciamo sul serio ma c'è un modo
per ricaricare la batteria o
semplicemente devo usare poca corrente
né cascata la torta va bene chi sarebbe
cosa devo fare qua dove siete
all'incidente morio dove siete
io quando sento dello schifo arrivarmi
nelle orecchie mi giro e faccio prima
tipo adesso non so se prendo niente no
ma ragazzi se io mi prenderò la faccia
degli armati etico dietro ma che storia
posso accedervi nell'armadietto tipo no
no perché sarebbe un'idea tra l'altro
non posso
chiodi si spegne la luce si spegne a
gesù ma ragazzi e un riccio io non posso
fare questa vita orribile perché senti i
propri passi di loro che arrivano è una
roba devastante possa aprire la porta ma
cos'è sta roba qua o dei soldi ma gesù
se mi fate ste cose un'altra volta vi
ammazzo con questi soldi che ogni tanto
leggo è uscita la televisione tipo the
ring come sono le tre di notte io la sto
giocando veramente bene ragazzi ma l'ho
detto è molto grave ecco
una volta però quando arrivano ragazzi è
bruttissimo serve strano
no ma ragazzi ma sto gioco e più brutto
dell'articolo 13 mar
ma tutto a posto non ho fatto in tempo
manco a capire che stava arrivando
qualcuno
ma figurati faccio un ultimo tentativo
ma proprio perché vi voglio male sono
tornato ma ed è padre puoi dirlo forte
samir allora fox si arriva da sinistra
forse è quella che è arrivata tutta di
corsa prima che mi ha spaventato e che
sono morto per colpa sua
devo chiudere istantaneamente la porta
quando arriva una propria devo fare devo
lanciarmi tipo gigi buffon
no ragazzi io non so non ho mai poi ve
lo giuro è la prima volta nella mia vita
vi gioca una roba così immersiva voglio
morire se avessi un power band persona
maledetta energia per aviv
mamma mia che che che prontezza di
spirito che ho avuto calmi calmi carini
e coccolosi vediamo se c'è kocsis e
fossi se arriva pozzi ma me lo devo
ricordare di fare così ceo ciccione più
di quella porta ma lardi di quella porta
lingua no ragazzi no senti the rock
fatti una vita credo che sia arrivata
forze ma non è riuscita eccola ha girato
la testata
sta tentando di sfondare la porta a
posto sono le cinque del mattino
secondo me se chiudo tutte e due pop
chiusa chiusa controllo soldi si è
chiuso tutte e due le porte adesso
secondo me arrivo alle 6 del mattino col
20 per cento di batteria forze ciao non
si fa non si fa fai schifo se n'è andato
così di tumori del rigore a destra ma
ragazzi ormai aiuto le allucinazioni
orribile quanto ci metti ad arrivare
alle 6 del mattino
ti va bene che questo non è un dito
medio 8 per cento
7 per cento io non arriverà l'assegno
del mattino legati va bene va bene sono
contento sono molto solo una volta non
raccolta ma non mi pare si spaventa per
favore per favore
ma sai che te lo puoi tenere del tutto
commestibile
lo sono mangiato ho guadagnato un trofeo
per essere mangiato freddi va bene
ragazzi ho fatto due notti c'è mai avrei
detto dato un euro
bene il video finisce qua perché
fortunatamente sono ancora vivo
continuerò nel prossimo episodio nel
possibile riprogrammare la notte tre la
vedete la felicità sul mio volto
neanch'io sono proprio contento di
essere tornata di fare ora non su questo
canale
mamma mia che a volte ciò delle idee
brillanti
magari non sia piaciuto che sarà
appannate freddi soir
giriamo al secondo episodio iscrivetevi
schiacciate anche la campanella che vi
arrivano le notifiche di quanto carico i
video da ragazzi
[Musica]